do something that's really authentic to
you that you genuinely want to like
breathe sleep dream about I get up every
day you know at like 6:00 a.m.
my journey is longer than others but for
me it's a lifestyle I believe in making
lifestyle changes and doing things for
you
hello believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn from entrepreneur and TV
personality Khloe Kardashian and my take
on her top ten rules to success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best also as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired by it as
well and if you leave it within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes
do something that's really authentic to
you and that you genuinely want to like
breathe sleep dream about like I am
super passionate about good American but
also just for what it represents and
stands for and then I also think that
reads through I think anything that we
do that's truly a part of our heart
that's when you have the longevity and
because you you care so much about it's
your baby I get up every day you know at
like 6:00 a.m. and it's just because my
mom always made us have responsibilities
doesn't matter how much money
someone has or doesn't have you have to
teach especially the more money you have
is the laser you people to have
structure and good work ethic that's
what makes you a better person so my mom
has always done that always made us have
responsibilities and I think it pays off
later in life or our Kardashian says I
personally felt I was beautiful bigger
was that true
well I never felt that I was ever big I
never looked at myself like oh my god I
was the fat one other people called me
that so I would say it to like beat them
to the punch like okay I'm the fat funny
one that was like I am so cute going to
this club and this really tight dress
that Kim would wear the same dresses
they would always do a side-by-side who
wore it better I'm like you know who or
better was camp right I felt so good
where does that confidence for that body
image come from because it's very hard I
think there are a lot of girls out there
who struggle with that so how did they
get that Chloe confidence you know it's
wit okay yeah it's really comes from
like loving yourself from within
if Instagram were to take a picture of
your soul what would that look like I
know my soul is beautiful I know I'm a
the person but that came from fat Chloe
and that's gonna come from skinny Chloe
like that will never change from me when
I was going through my divorce I really
was stressed out or like just needed a
place to go and I knew if I you know
we're so close my family and I so I
didn't want to keep going to my mom's
house and it would be like suspect like
what's going on with you so I turn to
the gym and I loved just being on the
elliptical and watching TV and like
really just it was working out and then
I realized how good I felt just doing
cardio like afterwards how clear my mind
felt
and then by that I was like oh wait and
as a by-product I started losing weight
but it wasn't my goal at first and then
I would say after a few months I was
like you know I'm gonna take this thing
seriously so I got my trainer Gunnar
Peterson and he's badass so then I was
like okay wait this is really hard and
serious but I took baby steps so my
journey is longer than others but for me
it's a lifestyle because my whole life I
was an emotional eater and I did not
have any of this under control so it was
new for me so I took baby steps in doing
that so I would say towards like my
divorce era but it took a minute for me
to then be like okay I'm going to take
this seriously addicted to the results
and then you think okay I'm gonna keep
going
definitely I'm Emma I'm really been on
energy and how I like someone I want to
be in business with and I'm not here for
the short term I want something that has
longevity and legs and I met Eman we
just completely clicked and it's not
about having a new denim line it was
about doing something that empowers
other women and something that is really
gonna break down barriers and I'm all
for when empowerment and I used to be
someone that they would label as
plus-size and I like that I don't want
to call that like I'm a woman with
curves that I'm what I would say is
average size at the time and I was very
proud of who I was and I felt like so
shamed at the time to go into boutiques
or to go denim shopping it was something
that was super hard for me so when I met
Emma and she was all for everything that
I stood for I was a badass woman and I
want to be in business with her and then
when everything that she said in our
initial meeting actually happened in all
of our meetings took place and we were
able to have this great line that stood
for not just jeans it stood for making
other people feel good about themselves
and women not having to be you know
segregated where this size has to go to
this size of this side of the shopping
center and these women who go to this
size like that's not what I wanted so
that's really something that was
authentic to me and that I stood behind
and that I felt I could be of movement
and hopefully encourage other brands to
follow in our footsteps nowadays with
social media it's way more intense I
really love the whole blocking thing on
Instagram these days and I am using it
every second I love it
I love to take social media breaks like
I'll post things and trying to not to
read the comments because if I was
posting something about me I post
something with me like raising money for
cancer awareness and I got reamed for it
so it's like no matter what I do you're
gonna have just haters so just know that
that's the way of the world
and just love yourself really inspired
this whole you know be the best me get
myself in shape in you know look like
this what inspired that moment I believe
in making lifestyle changes and doing
things for you um uh I've always worked
out but I just never found my groove
right and then when I was going through
my divorce I was super stressed I didn't
really know what to do when I was just
like well well my dad died I like turned
to drinking and like really destructive
behavior so I was like I don't want to
go back there I just kind of found my
refugee like my place of refuge was the
gym
you've been obviously working out what
like what is your thing what's your main
thing that you do because you look
terrific well thank you well for me it's
about lifestyle changes I've dieted
forever I'm a yo-yo dieter yo-yo weight
gainer and I was like okay I need to
make a change it's not about do like
losing 30 pounds in 30 days it's
unrealistic so I started making
lifestyle changes and working out often
I started slow it's been like about
three years and I've kept the weight off
that I've lost I don't know like I don't
weigh myself but I've lost about 40
pounds but over three years
said but I'm glad you said you getting
working at this for three years and it's
a lifestyle change because a lot of
people say I've been working out for
three days I'm different but it isn't
long it takes time yeah and it's
discouraging I mean for the first two
months I was like what I am sweating I'm
busting my ass I'm tired I'm hungry I'm
just whatever and you don't notice
anything and but you just keep on going
obviously something's gonna happen but
it your body takes a minute for that
change to show and that's the tortoise
wins wins wins the race so that's what I
want to do and I want to keep it off
forever when I was first starting out we
used to get pitch things all the time
and we're like bright-eyed and oh my god
is so exciting and you're new and you do
take on a lot of things that maybe
aren't as authentic or true to you or
you don't really believe in I think
you're young and excited and but by
doing that I've made a lot of mistakes
but which made me better for today I
think that your honesty on screen mm-hmm
it's so engaging and I think you feel um
a role model for younger girls which I
imagine is a hard mantle ya know how do
you deal with that well I mean I think
if you think about everything then it's
gonna become overwhelming and it might
be scary but I don't think of it like
that I think about I think for my little
sisters and for my nieces and nephews
how I want them to perceive me and what
I want the message to be for them and
then hopefully that message is good
enough for the rest of the world if I
want my loved ones to have it but it's
really just I mean being strong mind
body soul and just knowing that there's
so much more out there than social media
and I think that's what people
especially the youth get they get so
wrapped up in social media and trying to
appeal to people that don't even know
and you have to just make yourself happy
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Generation Y
asked me to if there's someone you like
me to profile in their future top ten
please check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick Charter to Vijay
Raj VJ thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
posting multiple videos on your YouTube
channel about it I really really really
appreciate the support and I'm so glad
that you enjoyed the book your minds if
of grayness leads to you one word so I
used an e for something important thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
I think success for me is a longevity
look I don't want this to be around this
year and no one knows about it in five
years a guy would like this to be a
brand that really grows roots and is
here for like years and years to come
and again you know who knows that
American is a name that could venture
off to men or children or whatever but
I'm just excited to see where that goes
and it's absolutely outrageous the
positive reaction we've gotten and it's
so it just makes me like so proud and
excited and like it's I'm just so happy
but it is like I'm dreaming so I'm
excited just to baby this a little bit
and then see where it goes